wenn du dieses jahr zum ersten mal
gemüse anbauen willst dann passiert
merck gut auf als erstes brauchst du
natürlich einen ort an dem du deine
beete anlegen kannst oder die top für
ihn stehen auf dem balkon ist dieser ort
sollte möglichst sonnig sein und auf
einer ebenen fläche zu gärtnern ist viel
leichter als an den steilen hang ich
finde dich immer ein paar gemüse ein die
schüler großzügig verzeihen das sind
super kandidaten für dein erstes
gartenjahr ich dachte am anfang ehrlich
gesagt dass ich eine weise alte frau
werden muss bevor mein garten so richtig
toll ist und schwupps zwei jahre später
waren wir dann schon an dem punkt dass
wir kaum noch gemüse zu kaufen mussten
damit er sich auf jeden fall nie
gerechnet also geht raus und fange
einfach an das wird bestimmt super